Everyone knows that Brie Larson's Captain
Marvel is as strong a superhero as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has ever seen — Marvel
head honcho Kevin Feige has even repeatedly
stated that she's the most powerful hero in
the entire film franchise so far.
With that in mind, it's not hugely surprising
that Carol was able to fly in and rescue Iron
Man and Nebula at the beginning of Avengers:
Endgame without even breaking a sweat.
And yet, Captain Marvel's Photon-blasting
fists and otherworldly strength aren't quite
enough to distract from one big question:
How did she actually find them?
Well, Avengers: Endgame co-director Joe Russo
has finally revealed the answer.
In the commentary track included on the digital
release of Avengers: Endgame, Russo explained
that Carol Danvers didn't just leave whatever
planet she was on and automatically know where
in space Tony Stark and Nebula were stranded.
After receiving an emergency page from Nick
Fury at the end of Avengers: Infinity War,
Carol went to Earth first and met with the
Avengers who had survived Thanos' snap.
Of course, many fans will actually remember
this happening, since it was depicted on-screen
during the post-credits scene for Captain
Marvel.
"Where's Fury?”
Thanks to Joe Russo, however, the final gap
in the story has been filled.
He explained:
"The missing narrative of course is that she
came to Earth, met the Avengers, was brought
up to speed on what was happening, and there's
some sort of homing beacon on that ship that
she tracks and brings the two of them back
to Earth."
For any Endgame viewers who hadn't stuck around
after Captain Marvel's credits, Carol's rescue
of Iron Man and Nebula may have been a little
confusing, given a lack of context behind
the scene and the "missing narrative" Russo
mentioned.
Nonetheless, it did an excellent job of tying
up the loose threads left dangling following
the Avengers: Infinity War post-credits scene,
in which Fury pages Carol seconds before he
crumbles into dust after Thanos' initial snap.
It was also a great way to bring Captain Marvel
into the present day after her '90s-set solo
movie, and demonstrate her enormous powers
to both the audience and the Avengers.
"Higher, further, faster, baby."
But this wasn't how Captain Marvel was intended
to be introduced.
Russo also explained that he, co-director
Anthony Russo, and screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely originally wrote
the rescue scene without the reveal that Carol
was responsible for it.
The team initially wanted to hide the fact
Captain Marvel was the hero who rocked up
to the Benatar and flew it back to Earth.
Instead, it would only be implied that she
was saving Iron Man and Nebula, at least at
first.
McFeely revealed:
"The idea would be that there'd be orange
light on Tony's face, he'd see something,
the audience wouldn't see it."
This is actually pretty close to what did
happen in Avengers: Endgame, but the earlier
cut of the movie wouldn't have let on that
it was Captain Marvel outside the Benatar,
saving the reveal for when she actually brings
the ship down to Earth.
Ultimately, the crew decided that this wouldn't
work as "a successful reveal", and instead
opted to show off Captain Marvel in all her
glory.
“Oh, yeah!"
Now that this Endgame mystery has finally
been solved, Marvel fans can focus their attention
on speculating when Captain Marvel will make
her return to the MCU.
Her sequel film wasn't announced as a Phase
4 project during Marvel's San Diego Comic-Con
panel, but fans aren't convinced that she'll
be sitting on the sidelines until after 2021.
Who knows?
Perhaps, in the coming years, Carol will swoop
in to save her fellow superheroes once more.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.